another government official facing
claims of coveted hypocrisy
mayor of austin texas now apologizing
for telling people to stay home and stop
the spread
in a video that he posted from his hotel
in mexico and that's not all casey
stegaller picks up reporting in dallas
here
today with us casey hey bill you can't
make this stuff
up but in order to truly understand the
timeline of the events here
we got to start at the beginning watch
mayor steve adler
the mayor of austin texas watched his
plea to the public
from a few weeks ago we need to
you know stay home if you can do
everything you can to try to keep the
numbers down
this is not the time to to relax we may
have to close things down
if we're not careful now you
notice the ceiling was showing well
perhaps adler had the camera tilted up
so people couldn't see
sand and palm trees because he was in
cabo san lucas mexico at his timeshare
been there a day
after flying down on his private jet
with eight other people
after his daughter got married and it
happened to be at a time when austin was
struggling with
a spike of new coronavirus infections
and hospitalizations
well late yesterday all of this news was
leaking and it started making the rounds
hours later you guessed it roll the tape
i'm sorry i took that trip it was a
lapse in judgment
and i want you to know that i apologize
i want you to know that i regret that
travel
i wouldn't travel now i didn't over
thanksgiving
and i won't over christmas
and and no one should that apology video
going on to say that he still
however did not violate any orders and
that he consulted his own health
officials before the wedding and the
trip
20 guests were invited to his daughter's
wedding which was held in a boutique
hotel in austin
while the city was under a stage 3
advisory meaning groups of 10 or more
discouraged mayor adler contends
everyone had to be tested for covet 19
before attending ma'am on a ghost right
yeah casey siegel and dallas nice to see
you sir